so you mentioned that tiffany haddish
was at the yellowstone so you all are
dating right
yes yes okay i never know anything about
that and then i found that out and i was
like that's so cool
i love both of you is it hard to date a
comedian because you feel like you're
like not funny at all
well i mean i will say i'm definitely
like
funny but in a corny way like i say
corny jokes
like dad jokes exactly but
it is it's not hard dating a comedian
but it's definitely i don't try to keep
up with her jokes even though i
i throw mine in but she's like on
another level so
but it does encourage me because
sometimes she'll say some jokes that are
not
as not as funny and but she you see some
[ __ ] in the armor
yeah yeah and it's corr and i'm
courageous i mean she's courageous
enough to do it so it lets me feel more
inspired to just say some
some stuff that doesn't work does she
try stuff on you like her material and
stuff for sure for sure
are you really honest with her or are
you like no you look great in that dress
when it comes oh no
no i'm honest i i say it like truthfully
i got to be uh
i got to be truthful with her and and
caring i'm caring but i'm honest and i'm
like i'm not going to
let her go out if i think something is
not fresh and not say nothing
not saying anything yeah and if a joke
is not really funny i'm not going
fake laugh i'm not that oh that's see
that's what you really need
sometimes um i do fake laugh
sometimes i feel like i have to because
people need it they need to feel like
they're funny in that moment oh man i
just i might give a smile i understand
the
the compassion you're trying to show by
giving a little bit it's not helpful
though because then you're sending them
out there
and saying you're awesome and it maybe
wasn't you know i learned
you're a better human than i am i
learned earlier now i'm gonna say that
but i learned early on
to just look like be honest like people
used to come to me with demo tapes
playing their music and i was like i got
to tell this person the truth
at first i used to say yeah it's good
it's great yeah
but now i'm like i want to tell them
something that could really be helpful
to them yeah so i got to tell them the
truth
so for my thing is funny you would be so
great on the voice that's what made me
good at that
is being on the voice because i i was
horrible that i was like everything's
awesome
and now i'm like well i got to be kind
of constructive and i don't want to lie
to him and i want to actually help him
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever